I have a game for you guys we're going a
little would you rather so picking
between the two things and briefly
explaining why you would choose one of
the others so here it's so exciting
account
would you rather mess up every single
take yourself or have somebody else mess
up your best date oh my god somebody
else mess up my best yeah because I'm
giving again I would have somebody else
mess up my bestie and and because I get
a chance to try it again
there you go you know I definitely
rather someone else blow my best that
but neither of those are good scenarios
but the pressure of continuously messing
up is so much worse than being annoyed
that someone ruined your take but saying
like would it be bad if someone else
messed up your best tag suggests that
you only had one good take and they
messed it up you know what you really
want is you want to just hit it out of
the park every take that's what you want
to just be nailing it all day would you
rather work with a real animal or a CG
creature real animals Gigi come on man
the ghetto he's got a fear about animals
how did you discover it you have a fear
of animals it's not a bit like the ever
thing people think it's of the fear it's
not a fear I have respect for the
animals it does and which means I don't
I don't know you I don't know you
my Kevin is just a poodle I don't know
that pool and I don't know what that
fool is thinking right now this could be
a bad day for that poodle why do I want
to put myself in a position to be a part
of the repercussions in a bad day leave
that fool alone Kevin okay keep that
pool over there he's missed the animal
Gunnar always wants to be the stronger
no I marry someone with the idea what is
that what is that was that be free over
there
Oh would you rather work with someone
who improvises too much or sticks to the
script too much improvises too much
would be my answer give mine too you
know that did you guys improvise that
opening scene with the two you together
a lot because it feels so natural and
effortless to me I don't think either of
us remember doing the scene would you
rather have to fake sneeze or fake vomit
in a scene ooh
yeah fake sneeze is so much easier I'll
do fake sneeze I most certainly cannot
okay yeah you really was that thank you
very time I don't know what that was
with with fake vomit you're gonna need
special effects or you're gonna need
like a tube would you rather have to run
a lot in a scene or eat a lot in a scene
oh yeah well cuz that cuz I run why are
you laughing at that
ah eat a lot innocent
like yeah hey mama eat a lot you run a
lot we don't like to run yeah I don't
like to run like now we're not in the
run around out worthy and but you know
the trick about that right you guys know
that I think I just spit it back yeah
yeah you got a bag over here E then as
soon as the director says cut the bag
it's really disgusting I'll go I'll go
run I don't eat you know everything I
don't eat in movies you never see me
even you oh wow now I'm determined to
wrangle butter you're never gonna see a
thing where I eat and make a cake you
know I never have to digest the cake but
I learned early in my career because I
fell for it I had to eat a hotdog oh man
multiple see I'm eating the hot dog
because I'm young so I don't know so I'm
eating it all day I don't know about the
spit bucket nothing this is nobody
brought a van so I'm just eating hot
dogs all day get poor your stomach hurts
next day they're like why don't you spit
bucket you didn't have to do it I said
I'll never do it again so if you look at
it I never eat movies that was his last
day doing porn I don't